Summers just around the corner, so give your body the care it deserves with Osea's best-selling Andaria algae body oil. Created by infusing Andaria seaweed in barrels of botanical oils, it leaves skin silky, soft, and glowing. Plus, it's clinically proven to improve elasticity and deeply moisturize without feeling greasy. It's safe, clean, vegan skincare. Get 10% off your first order at OseaMalibu.com with code GLOW, plus free shipping on orders over $60. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this
夏天即将来临，快用 Osea 最畅销的 Andaria 藻类身体油给你的身体应有的呵护吧。它通过将 Andaria 海藻浸泡在植物油桶中制成，能让肌肤如丝般柔滑、光泽动人。此外，经临床证明，它能改善弹性并深层滋润，且毫无油腻感。这是一款安全、纯净、纯素的护肤品。在 OseaMalibu.com 使用代码 GLOW 购买首单可享 9 折优惠，订单满 60 美元还可免运费。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用内或我们网站上的本期节目说明。
episode on your app or on our website. At around 3pm on Wednesday, September 20, 2017, a resident in the Southfields District of Southwest London was disturbed by a foul odor. Peering outside, they noticed a black smoke emanating from their next door neighbour's rear garden from what appeared to be some kind of weird barbecue. The concerned resident went and knocked on their neighbour's door to check if everything was okay, but there was no answer. Shrugging it off, they went about their day as the repugnant smoke continued to spiral above the neighbourhood. Three hours later, the resident could no longer ignore it. They phoned emergency services and reported the strange fire burning on Wimbledon Park Road.
2017 年 9 月 20 日星期三下午 3 点左右，伦敦西南部南菲尔兹区的一位居民被一股恶臭惊扰。向外望去，他们注意到隔壁邻居的后花园冒出黑烟，看起来像是某种奇怪的烧烤。这位忧心忡忡的居民去敲了邻居的门，想确认是否一切正常，但无人应答。他们没太在意，继续忙自己的事，而那股令人作呕的烟雾继续在社区上空盘旋。三小时后，这位居民再也无法忽视它了。他们拨打了紧急服务电话，报告了温布尔登公园路上的那场奇怪火灾。
Firefighters arrived at the address at 6.20pm. A slim, balding man with olive skin and graying facial hair opened the door. He was 40-year-old Weesam Meadowney, known to friends as Sam. Weesam told the firefighters there was nothing to worry about, he was simply having a barbecue. But the firefighters wanted to check it out to make sure it didn't present any fire hazards. They walked through Weesam's small two-bedroom flat and out a set of French doors into the rear garden. Just as Weesam had described, several pieces of chicken were grilling on a small barbecue. Alongside it blazed an open bonfire, which was the source of the thick, foul-smelling smoke.
消防员于下午 6 点 20 分到达该地址。一名身材瘦削、秃顶、橄榄色皮肤、留着灰白胡须的男子开了门。他就是 40 岁的威萨姆·梅多尼（Weesam Meadowney），朋友们称他为萨姆。威萨姆告诉消防员没什么可担心的，他只是在烧烤。但消防员想检查一下，以确保没有火灾隐患。他们穿过威萨姆狭小的两居室公寓，通过一套法式门来到后花园。正如威萨姆所描述的那样，小烤架上确实烤着几块鸡肉。旁边燃着一堆露天篝火，那正是浓烈、恶臭烟雾的来源。
The fire was remarkably close to the door, so firefighters deemed it a hazard and extinguished the flames. One of them, Thomas Hunt, then turned to Weesam and asked what he was burning. Weesam said it was the carcass of a sheep which he'd purchased earlier from the Wimbledon market. Thomas eyed the charred remains. Among two blackened logs were human fingers and a nose. Upon realizing that he was looking at the remnants of a human body, firefighter Thomas Hunt wanted to confront Weesam Mediney. But he wasn't sure how the man would react and didn't want to put the rest of his team in danger. Thomas paused for a moment. In response to Weesam's claim that he was burning a sheep carcass, Thomas finally said, bollocks. Weesam seemed unperturbed. He calmly
火势离门非常近，消防员认为这存在隐患，于是扑灭了火焰。其中一名消防员托马斯·亨特（Thomas Hunt）转过身问威萨姆在烧什么。威萨姆说那是他早些时候从温布尔登市场买来的一只羊的尸体。托马斯盯着那些烧焦的残骸。在两根发黑的木头之间，有人的手指和一个鼻子。当意识到自己看到的是一具人体残骸时，消防员托马斯·亨特想与威萨姆·梅多尼对质。但他不确定此人会有什么反应，也不想让团队的其他成员陷入危险。托马斯停顿了片刻。针对威萨姆声称他在烧羊尸体的说法，托马斯最终说：“胡说八道。”威萨姆似乎并未感到不安。他冷静地
shrugged off the comment and went to sit down. It was then that Thomas detected a look of resignation on Weesam's face as though he knew he'd been caught. While waiting for police to arrive, the firefighters sifted through the ashes and found items of clothing, jewelry and a pair of badly charred eyeglasses. Pieces of cooked chicken had also been thrown on the burning body in a crass attempt to disguise it. There was something else adding to the disturbing nature of the discovery. The body looked particularly small and frail. For the fire crew, this indicated one thing, that it was the body of a child. The police soon arrived and assessed the scene. The body was so badly burned that they couldn't determine the person's age or gender. They asked Weesam who it
耸了耸肩，坐了下来。就在那时，托马斯察觉到威萨姆脸上露出一丝认命的神情，仿佛他知道自己被抓住了。在等待警察到达时，消防员翻找灰烬，发现了衣物、珠宝和一副严重烧焦的眼镜。为了掩盖罪行，几块熟鸡肉也被粗暴地扔在燃烧的尸体上。还有一点让这一发现更加令人不安。尸体看起来特别瘦小虚弱。对于消防队员来说，这说明了一件事：这是一具儿童的尸体。警察很快赶到并评估了现场。尸体烧得太严重，无法确定死者的年龄或性别。他们问威萨姆那是
was. He simply responded, it's not a child. 36-year-old Sabrina Quadaire was a glamorous woman. Born in Algeria but raised in Paris, she took great pride in her appearance. With long dark hair, olive skin and a keen sense of style, she was often mistaken for reality TV star Kim Kardashian. Having established herself as a successful fashion designer and makeup artist, Sabrina was awarded with invites to trendy events where she mingled with the rich and famous. Sabrina met Weesam Metinee at a Parisian Fun Fair in 2001. Weesam had been immediately struck by her beauty and it wasn't long before he was completely besotted with her. Sabrina eventually moved from Paris to London and Weesam, also a French Algerian, happily followed her.
谁。他只是回答：“那不是孩子。” 36 岁的萨布丽娜·夸代尔（Sabrina Quadaire）是一位迷人的女性。她出生于阿尔及利亚，在巴黎长大，对自己的外表非常自豪。她留着深色长发，有着橄榄色皮肤和敏锐的时尚感，常被误认为是真人秀明星金·卡戴珊。作为一名成功的时装设计师和化妆师，萨布丽娜经常受邀参加时尚活动，与名流显贵往来。萨布丽娜于 2001 年在巴黎的一个游乐场遇到了威萨姆·梅蒂尼（Weesam Metinee）。威萨姆立刻被她的美貌所吸引，没过多久就对她彻底着迷。萨布丽娜最终从巴黎搬到了伦敦，同样是法籍阿尔及利亚人的威萨姆也开心地追随她而去。
They'd called England home ever since. The couple had periods of separation throughout their 17-year-long relationship, during which Sabrina had two children to two different men, but she and Weesam always wound up back together. They'd been living in the rented Wimbledon Park Road flat since 2013. Following the discovery of the burnt human remains at the couple's home, Weesam Metinee was placed in handcuffs and escorted to the police station. Police attempted to interview him, but Weesam remained silent when questioned. When Sabrina Quadaire returned home with her two young sons, there was a collective sense of relief that her and her children were safe. But the question remained, whose body was found in the pyre?
从那以后，他们就把英国当作了家。在 17 年的恋情中，这对情侣曾多次分分合合，期间萨布丽娜与两个不同的男人生了两个孩子，但她和威萨姆最终总是复合。自 2013 年以来，他们一直住在温布尔登公园路的一间出租公寓里。在两人的家中发现烧焦的人体残骸后，威萨姆·梅蒂尼被戴上手铐带往警察局。警方试图审问他，但威萨姆在被讯问时保持沉默。当萨布丽娜·夸代尔带着她的两个年幼儿子回到家时，大家感到一阵集体宽慰，认为她和孩子们是安全的。但问题依然存在：火堆中发现的尸体到底是谁？
Sabrina was stunned by the police presence and asked what was going on. An officer told her that Weesam was found burning a body in the backyard. This came as a huge shock to Sabrina. She said she'd been out all day and that things at home seemed completely normal when she left. In the afternoon, she picked up her children from school and took them to an after-school club, at which time Weesam endeavoured to burn the unidentified body in their back garden. Sabrina couldn't believe what she was hearing. Meanwhile, police questioned the couple's neighbours to see if they'd noticed anything out of the ordinary. Southfields was an affluent family-oriented suburb labelled as one of the
萨布丽娜被警察的出现惊呆了，询问发生了什么事。一名警官告诉她，威萨姆被发现正在后院焚烧一具尸体。这对萨布丽娜来说是一个巨大的打击。她说她整天都在外面，离开时家里的一切看起来完全正常。下午，她从学校接回孩子并带他们去了课后俱乐部，而就在那时，威萨姆试图在他们的后花园焚烧那具身份不明的尸体。萨布丽娜简直不敢相信自己的耳朵。与此同时，警方询问了这对情侣的邻居，看他们是否注意到任何异常情况。南菲尔兹是一个富裕且以家庭为导向的郊区，被称为伦敦
best places to live in London, and crimes of this nature were unheard of. Neighbours were in disbelief. They knew the residents of the house to be a relatively normal family that mostly kept to themselves. They weren't very involved with the community and didn't attend street parties, but there was nothing much else to note. No one had seen or heard anything untoward in the days leading up to the fire. When they thought about it, however, they realised they hadn't seen the couple's young nanny in weeks. She was often sighted out and about running errands for her host family and picking up Sabrina's children from school, but not lately. What's more, neighbours had described her as wearing eyeglasses similar to those found in the fire.
最适合居住的地方之一，这种性质的犯罪闻所未闻。邻居们感到难以置信。他们知道这户人家是相对正常的家庭，平时大多独来独往。他们不太参与社区活动，也不参加街区派对，但除此之外没什么特别值得注意的。在火灾发生前的几天里，没有人看到或听到任何异常情况。然而，当他们仔细回想时，意识到已经几周没见过这对情侣的年轻保姆了。她经常被看到在外面为雇主家跑腿，并从学校接萨布丽娜的孩子，但最近没有了。更重要的是，邻居们形容她戴着一副与火堆中发现的眼镜相似的眼镜。
When asked about her nanny, Sabrina Quider claimed she had resigned two days earlier and returned home to France. Police asked for the nanny's name, but Sabrina could only remember her first name, Sophie. She had hired Sophie 18 months prior to help with the children while Wiesem was away for work. This immediately struck the police's odd. After employing and living with Sophie for such a long time, it seemed absurd that Sabrina didn't know her last name. They suspected that Sabrina knew more than she was letting on and took her to the station for further questioning. Given the level of destruction, DNA testing would be required to confirm the identity of the body Wiesem was attempting to destroy. But police was certain it was the
当被问及保姆时，萨布丽娜·夸代尔声称她两天前辞职回法国了。警方询问保姆的名字，但萨布丽娜只能想起她的名字叫索菲（Sophie）。她在 18 个月前雇佣了索菲，以便在威萨姆外出工作时帮忙照顾孩子。这立刻让警方觉得很奇怪。在雇佣并与索菲共同生活了这么久之后，萨布丽娜竟然不知道她的姓氏，这显得非常荒谬。他们怀疑萨布丽娜知道的比她透露的要多，于是将她带到警察局进行进一步审问。鉴于破坏程度，需要进行 DNA 检测才能确认威萨姆试图销毁的尸体的身份。但警方确信那是
couple's live-in nanny, 21-year-old Sophie Leonet. When faced with this revelation, Sabrina caved. She revealed that Sophie was incompetent at her job and didn't do any of the tasks she was hired to do. Instead, she laced around on the couch, glued to her smartphone. Sabrina said, she was waiting for us to serve her. It was as if we were working for her and not her for us. She said that Sophie had fallen in with the wrong crowd and had been drinking heavily. Sabrina also suspected that she had been stealing from her, as a diamond pendant had gone missing from the house. Sophie's behavior soon took a sinister turn. Sabrina discovered she had begun a relationship with Sabrina's ex-boyfriend, a man named Mark Walton, who was the biological
这对情侣的住家保姆，21 岁的索菲·里昂内（Sophie Leonet）。面对这一揭露，萨布丽娜崩溃了。她透露索菲工作不称职，根本不做任何她被雇佣去做的工作。相反，她整天瘫在沙发上，盯着智能手机。萨布丽娜说：“她在等我们伺候她。就好像是我们为她工作，而不是她为我们工作。”她说索菲结交了坏朋友，酗酒严重。萨布丽娜还怀疑她一直在偷东西，因为家里丢了一个钻石吊坠。索菲的行为很快变得险恶起来。萨布丽娜发现她开始与萨布丽娜的前男友马克·沃尔顿（Mark Walton）交往，此人是萨布丽娜
father of Sabrina's youngest son. Sabrina revealed that Mark had sexually abused their son, and that Sophie had been allowing it to happen. Not only allowing it, but facilitating the meetings by bringing the young boy to Mark without Sabrina's knowledge. When Wiesem found out what was happening, it was the final straw. Days earlier at around midnight on Monday, September 18, Sabrina was sleeping when Wiesem came into the room and woke her up. He told her he had confronted Sophie about the meetings with Mark and the abuse against Sabrina's son. He lost his temper and hit Sophie, causing her to fly back and hit her head against the bathroom wall. Her body stopped moving. It was obvious that she
最小儿子的亲生父亲。萨布丽娜透露，马克曾性虐待他们的儿子，而索菲一直对此听之任之。不仅是听之任之，甚至还通过在萨布丽娜不知情的情况下将小男孩带给马克来促成这些会面。当威萨姆发现发生了什么事时，这是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。几天前，即 9 月 18 日星期一午夜左右，萨布丽娜正在睡觉，威萨姆走进房间叫醒了她。他告诉她，他已经就与马克的会面以及对萨布丽娜儿子的虐待问题与索菲对质。他失去了理智，打了索菲，导致她向后飞去，头部撞到了浴室墙壁。她的身体停止了移动。很明显，她
was dead. Wiesem and Sabrina panicked. They were scared of what it might mean for their family if they told the truth. They couldn't risk it. They decided to keep Sophie's death a secret and burn her body so no one would ever find out. If anyone asked where she was, they'd simply say she had decided to return home to France. They stashed her belongings in her suitcase which they hid inside their small garden shed. When pressed, Wiesem Madouni backed Sabrina's claims. He said that in an effort to extract information about Mark Walton and the child abuse, he had Sophie sit in a full bath and would periodically hold her head under the water to compel her to answer his questions. He was eventually so overcome with anger,
已经死了。威萨姆和萨布丽娜惊慌失措。他们害怕如果说出真相，对他们的家庭意味着什么。他们不敢冒险。他们决定隐瞒索菲的死讯并焚烧她的尸体，这样就不会有人发现。如果有人问她在哪，他们就说她决定回法国了。他们把她的行李塞进手提箱，藏在花园的小棚子里。当被追问时，威萨姆·马杜尼（Wiesem Madouni）支持了萨布丽娜的说法。他说，为了获取有关马克·沃尔顿和虐待儿童的信息，他让索菲坐在装满水的浴缸里，并会定期把她的头按在水下，强迫她回答他的问题。他最终被愤怒冲昏了头脑，
he punched Sophie in the face, causing her head to strike the tiles. She lost consciousness and her body then slipped under the water. Wiesem tried to revive Sophie, explaining that he had never intended to kill her or cause her serious injury. He had simply lost control. When it was clear she was deceased, he agreed to burning her body to protect his family. Police were baffled by the story, but Sabrina had evidence to back up her claims. She produced a confession allegedly penned by Sophie. One part read, Mark Walton asked me to come and see him. He started to touch my breasts and he kissed my neck.
他打了索菲的脸，导致她的头撞到了瓷砖上。她失去了知觉，身体随后滑入水中。威萨姆试图救醒索菲，解释说他从未想过要杀死她或对她造成严重伤害。他只是失去了控制。当确定她已经死亡时，他同意焚烧她的尸体以保护他的家人。警方对这个故事感到困惑，但萨布丽娜有证据支持她的说法。她出示了一份据称由索菲亲笔写的供词。其中一部分写道：“马克·沃尔顿让我去见他。他开始摸我的胸部，还亲吻了我的脖子。”
Mark offered me some money, and he asked me to come back with Sabrina's youngest child. Experts confirmed the handwriting was indeed Sophie's. Sophie's body had been so badly burnt that the exact cause of her death couldn't be established. Her lower jawbone, four of her ribs and her sternum were all found to have been fractured. The timing of these injuries were particularly noteworthy. Forensic experts concluded that the jawbone fracture happened hours before Sophie was killed, hinting that there was more to her bathtub interrogation than Wiesem just holding her head under water. The chest injuries were even more suspicious.
“马克给了我一些钱，并让我带着萨布丽娜最小的孩子一起去。”专家证实笔迹确实是索菲的。索菲的尸体被烧得太严重，无法确定确切的死因。她的下颌骨、四根肋骨和胸骨都被发现有骨折。这些伤口的发生时间特别值得注意。法医专家得出结论，下颌骨骨折发生在索菲被杀前几小时，暗示在浴缸审讯中，威萨姆不仅仅是将她的头按在水下。胸部伤口甚至更可疑。
They were found to have occurred days before she died. Investigators examined Wiesem and Sabrina's mobile phones, and what they found was shocking. Over a 12-day period, the couple had recorded over eight hours of audio and video footage, in which they subjected Sophie to harrowing interrogations. Using violence and coercion, they relentlessly tried to get her to confess to a range of offences. They accused her of being a spy, a thief, a heavy drug user, and a pedophile. But, at the heart of the interrogations lay one person, Mark Walton. Sabrina and Wiesem applied immense pressure and intimidation trying to make Sophie admit
它们被发现是在她死前几天发生的。调查人员检查了威萨姆和萨布丽娜的手机，发现的内容令人震惊。在 12 天的时间里，这对情侣录制了超过 8 小时的音频和视频片段，在这些片段中，他们对索菲进行了令人毛骨悚然的审讯。他们使用暴力和胁迫手段，无情地试图让她承认一系列罪行。他们指控她是间谍、小偷、重度吸毒者和恋童癖。但是，审讯的核心人物是马克·沃尔顿。萨布丽娜和威萨姆施加了巨大的压力和恐吓，试图让索菲承认
that she was having a sexual relationship with Mark, and that the two were in cahoots to sexually exploit Sabrina's sons. The couple claimed they had evidence that Sophie had brought Mark to their flat so he could drug and sexually abuse the family. They compared Sophie to a Nazi collaborator and told her she was worse than a murderer. Sabrina said, You made a huge mistake. You delivered a four-year-old into the hands of a pedophile. Mark paid you, Sophie. I have evidence. You cannot go home without telling us everything. Sabrina told Sophie that she had friends in high places, including then-US President Donald Trump, and that she could easily have her locked up. She threatened Sophie with 40 years in prison,
她与马克有性关系，并且两人勾结在一起性剥削萨布丽娜的儿子。这对情侣声称他们有证据表明索菲曾将马克带到他们的公寓，以便他可以给家人下药并进行性虐待。他们将索菲比作纳粹合作者，并告诉她她比杀人犯还糟糕。萨布丽娜说：“你犯了一个巨大的错误。你把一个四岁的孩子交到了恋童癖手中。马克付钱给你了，索菲。我有证据。你不交代一切就别想回家。”萨布丽娜告诉索菲，她在高层有朋友，包括当时的美国总统唐纳德·特朗普，她可以轻易地把她关起来。她威胁索菲说要判她 40 年监禁，
saying, Close your eyes for one minute and imagine yourself every day in a cage like an animal with other people inside. That's not a laughing matter. From the recordings, it was clear that Sabrina was the main instigator. During one interrogation, she said, On my mother's life, I am not going to leave you alone. I will not touch you, but I will not leave you alone until you tell me the truth. Is this clear? Do you understand? You will not go back to France until you've told me the truth. I am going to spoil your life as you have spoiled mine. Have you understood that? But Weesam also played a significant role. In one recording, he called Sophie a liar
说：“闭上眼睛一分钟，想象一下你每天像动物一样被关在笼子里，里面还有其他人。这可不是开玩笑的事。”从录音中可以清楚地看出，萨布丽娜是主要煽动者。在一次审讯中，她说：“以我母亲的生命起誓，我不会放过你。我不会碰你，但如果你不告诉我真相，我就不会让你安宁。这清楚吗？你明白吗？在你告诉我真相之前，你别想回法国。你毁了我的生活，我也要毁了你的生活。你听懂了吗？”但威萨姆也扮演了重要角色。在一段录音中，他称索菲是骗子，
and told her she wasn't allowed to return back to France until she'd revealed the whole truth, and nothing but the truth. It was clear that Sophie was terrified. She rarely responded to the couple's hounding, but when she did, her voice was meek and barely audible. At first and for a long while, she denied everything and seemed genuinely confused about what the couple were accusing her of. The extent of the physical violence wasn't clear, but loud thumping sounds indicated that Sabrina hit Sophie multiple times. The final video was filmed shortly before midnight on Monday, September 18, 2017. Investigators couldn't believe what they were watching.
并告诉她，在揭露全部真相之前，她不被允许回法国。很明显，索菲被吓坏了。她很少回应这对情侣的追问，但当她回应时，声音微弱且几乎听不见。起初，在很长一段时间里，她否认了一切，似乎对这对情侣指控她的事情感到非常困惑。身体暴力的程度尚不清楚，但沉重的撞击声表明萨布丽娜多次殴打索菲。最后一段视频拍摄于 2017 年 9 月 18 日星期一午夜前不久。调查人员简直不敢相信他们所看到的。
In stark contrast to the healthy, happy young woman who had left France 18 months earlier, Sophie Lyonnais was a shadow of her former self. Her body was gaunt and skeletal as though she hadn't eaten in weeks. She looked frail and broken. Her once thick and wavy brown hair had become thin and flat. This explained why the remains in the fire looked childlike. It was heart-wrenching to watch. The emaciated Sophie sat in front of a fireplace in the Wimbledon Park Road flat, a knitted blanket draped across her lap. There, the months of abuse and violent interrogations came to a head. Sophie finally broke. She confessed to having an affair with Mark Walton. In an even more shocking revelation, she admitted that she drugged Wiesem so that Mark could come
与 18 个月前离开法国时那个健康、快乐的年轻女性形成鲜明对比的是，索菲·里昂内已经判若两人。她的身体消瘦如骨，仿佛几周没吃东西了。她看起来虚弱而破碎。她曾经浓密而卷曲的棕色头发变得稀疏而扁平。这就解释了为什么火堆中的残骸看起来像孩子。看着这一幕令人心碎。消瘦的索菲坐在温布尔登公园路公寓的壁炉前，膝盖上披着一条针织毯子。在那里，数月的虐待和暴力审讯达到了顶峰。索菲终于崩溃了。她承认与马克·沃尔顿有染。在一个更令人震惊的揭露中，她承认她给威萨姆下了药，以便马克可以来到
over to the flat and sexually assault him as well. Sabrina and Wiesem intended to hand the footage they had taken of Sophie's confession to police as evidence of her crimes. However, just hours after Sophie admitted to knowing and abetting Mark Walton, she was dead. Mark Walton was going about his morning in his new home of Los Angeles when he received a phone call from the police in London. He was shocked to hear that Sabrina Quider had just accused him of child molestation in collaboration with her nanny, who had just been killed. Mark couldn't believe what he was hearing. Although he'd come to expect extreme behaviour from Sabrina, this was beyond anything he had so far endured. He vehemently denied the lurid claims,
公寓并对他进行性侵犯。萨布丽娜和威萨姆打算将他们拍摄的索菲供词录像交给警方作为她犯罪的证据。然而，就在索菲承认勾结马克·沃尔顿的几个小时后，她就死了。马克·沃尔顿正在洛杉矶的新家中开始他的一天，这时他接到了伦敦警方的电话。听到萨布丽娜·夸代尔刚刚指控他与她的保姆勾结猥亵儿童，而保姆刚刚被杀，他感到震惊。马克简直不敢相信自己的耳朵。尽管他已经预料到萨布丽娜会有极端行为，但这超出了他迄今为止所忍受的一切。他强烈否认了这些荒诞的指控，
telling police he'd never even met Sophie Lyonnais or communicated with her. He wasn't even in the country during the dates Sabrina claimed the child abuse took place. Mark insisted he had nothing to hide. He offered to provide his passport, phone, and anything else the police required to prove his innocence. For Mark Walton, his life changed forever in 2011 when he walked into a bank in London. Mark was a well-known figure in the music industry, having been one of the founding members of the wildly popular Irish boy band Boyzone. He eventually left Boyzone to pursue a career in music production and had gone on to work with such artists as Jennifer Lopez and Enrique Iglesias. It was in the bank in London when he
告诉警方他甚至从未见过索菲·里昂内，也没有与她交流过。在萨布丽娜声称发生虐待儿童的日期里，他甚至不在那个国家。马克坚称他没有什么可隐瞒的。他主动提出提供护照、手机以及警方证明他清白所需的任何其他东西。对于马克·沃尔顿来说，他的人生在 2011 年走进伦敦一家银行时永远改变了。马克是音乐界的名人，曾是广受欢迎的爱尔兰男孩乐队 Boyzone 的创始成员之一。他最终离开 Boyzone 去追求音乐制作事业，并曾与詹妮弗·洛佩兹和恩里克·伊格莱西亚斯等艺人合作。就是在伦敦的那家银行里，他
first laid eyes on Sabrina Quiddare. He was immediately attracted to her and they struck up a conversation. With good looks, style, and a common interest in the high life, the two quickly became a picture perfect couple. It wasn't long before they moved in together and Sabrina eventually became pregnant. The early days of their relationship were happy, but once Mark's love goggles wore off, he saw Sabrina for who she really was. She had a wild temper and her mood could dramatically switch over the most trivial of things. She often acted irrationally without explanation. During some rough patches in their relationship, she called the police to report that Mark was hiring male sex workers, which was untrue.
第一次见到了萨布丽娜·夸代尔。他立刻被她吸引，两人聊了起来。凭借出众的外貌、时尚感以及对奢华生活的共同兴趣，两人很快成为了一对完美的伴侣。没过多久他们就同居了，萨布丽娜最终怀孕了。他们恋情的早期是幸福的，但当马克的爱情滤镜褪去后，他看清了萨布丽娜的真面目。她脾气暴躁，情绪会因为最琐碎的事情而剧烈波动。她经常无缘无故地表现得不理智。在他们关系的一些艰难时期，她打电话给警察举报马克雇佣男性性工作者，这根本不是事实。
She also took to firing any nanny the pair hired to assist them, accusing them of stealing from her and of being romantically interested in Mark. She'd gone as far as installing hidden cameras throughout their home, which Mark was unaware of until he stumbled upon them himself. The couple split for good in 2014, after which Sabrina rekindled her relationship with Wisa Meduni. Mark moved to Los Angeles and continued to help support Sabrina financially, even paying the rent of her new Southfields flat. Regardless, she seemed determined to make his life difficult. Over the years, Sabrina reported Mark to the police over 30 times for a range of bizarre and baseless offenses, including that he'd once tried to kill her,
她还解雇了他们雇来帮忙的任何保姆，指控她们偷东西并对马克有浪漫兴趣。她甚至在家里安装了隐藏摄像头，马克直到自己偶然发现它们时才知情。这对情侣在 2014 年彻底分手，之后萨布丽娜与威萨姆·梅多尼重燃旧情。马克搬到了洛杉矶，并继续在经济上支持萨布丽娜，甚至支付她新南菲尔兹公寓的租金。尽管如此，她似乎决心让他的生活变得艰难。多年来，萨布丽娜因一系列离奇且毫无根据的罪名向警方举报马克 30 多次，包括他曾试图杀死她、
had hacked her phone and emails, and was trying to control her using black magic. Things only escalated when Mark completely cut Sabrina off financially. Amongst the many other outlandish accusations, she accused him and his friends of hiring a helicopter to spy on her. Some of Sabrina's claims were plain ludicrous, like the time she reported Mark for sexually mistreating her cat when she never even owned a cat in the first place. The most outrageous was when Sabrina created a fake Facebook profile to publicly spread lies alleging Mark was a pedophile. Mark had been putting up with this issue privately for some time, after Sabrina falsely complained to social services that Mark had sexually abused
黑进她的手机和电子邮件，并试图用黑魔法控制她。当马克彻底切断对萨布丽娜的经济支持时，事情进一步升级。在许多其他荒谬的指控中，她指控他和他的朋友雇佣直升机监视她。萨布丽娜的一些说法简直荒唐可笑，比如有一次她举报马克性虐待她的猫，而她根本就没有养过猫。最离谱的是，萨布丽娜创建了一个虚假的 Facebook 个人资料，公开散布谎言，声称马克是恋童癖。马克私下里忍受这个问题已经有一段时间了，此前萨布丽娜曾向社会服务机构虚假投诉马克性虐待
their son. But this was the first time she had accused him publicly. Sabrina was arrested as a result, and she reluctantly accepted a caution for sending malicious communications. The most recent incident had occurred just one month prior to Sophie Lyonnais' death in August 2017. Sabrina had called police to report that Sophie had taken her son to meet with Mark against her wishes. There, Mark threatened to kill the boy's family. Given Sabrina's previous history of false reports, police didn't believe her, and therefore no action was taken. The following month, Sabrina recorded a dejected and exhausted Sophie at 11.32 am, mere hours before she died. She pressed Sophie to admit that Mark
他们的儿子。但这是她第一次公开指控他。萨布丽娜因此被捕，她不情愿地接受了因发送恶意信息而受到的警告。最近的一次事件发生在索菲·里昂内 2017 年 8 月去世前一个月。萨布丽娜曾打电话给警察，报告索菲违背她的意愿带她的儿子去见马克。在那里，马克威胁要杀死这个男孩的家人。鉴于萨布丽娜之前有虚假报告的历史，警方不相信她，因此没有采取任何行动。次月，萨布丽娜在上午 11 点 32 分录下了沮丧且疲惫的索菲，就在她去世前几个小时。她逼迫索菲承认马克·
Walton had been at their house, despite Sophie telling her time and again that she had never met him. Sabrina then told her, I hate lies, I hate, I hate, I hate lies, so stop telling lies and tell me the truth. For locals of Southfields, it was common to see Sophie Lyonnais out and about with Sabrina's children, often holding hands. It was clear that she was a hard worker, and the children seemed to adore her. Contrary to what Sabrina told police about Sophie being lazy and useless, she had been doing a standout job with the children. A kind and gentle soul with unlimited patience, Sophie put enormous effort into her work, which took its toll on her.
沃尔顿曾去过他们家，尽管索菲一次又一次地告诉她，她从未见过他。萨布丽娜随后告诉她：“我讨厌谎言，我讨厌，我讨厌，我讨厌谎言，所以别再撒谎了，告诉我真相。”对于南菲尔兹的当地人来说，经常看到索菲·里昂内和萨布丽娜的孩子们在一起，经常手牵手。很明显，她工作努力，孩子们似乎很爱她。与萨布丽娜告诉警察索菲懒惰且无用的话相反，她在照顾孩子方面做得非常出色。索菲是一个善良温柔、极具耐心的人，她在工作中投入了巨大的努力，这让她付出了代价。
It wasn't in her nature to hurt anyone, especially not the very children she had been employed to look after. At one point, she even helped the kids set up a mini stand on the street to sell sweets and biscuits. But in the weeks leading up to Sophie's death, neighbors had seen less and less of her. During one visit to the local fish and chip shop, owner Michael could tell by Sophie's body language that something wasn't right. He'd suspected the nanny wasn't doing well, as he noticed she often had tears in her eyes. Michael asked Sophie what was wrong, and she confided that Sabrina had beat her.
伤害任何人，尤其是她受雇照顾的孩子，这绝非她的本性。有一次，她甚至帮孩子们在街上摆了一个小摊卖糖果和饼干。但在索菲去世前的几周里，邻居们越来越少见到她。在一次去当地炸鱼薯条店时，店主迈克尔从索菲的肢体语言中看出有些不对劲。他怀疑保姆过得不好，因为他注意到她眼里经常含着泪水。迈克尔问索菲怎么了，她吐露说萨布丽娜打了她。
Michael was shocked. He was friendly with Sabrina Quedere and Wisa Meduny, as the trio were in talks of doing business together. He asked Sophie what happened to cause the beating. The reason was preposterous. She had dropped the butter. Michael's heart went out to Sophie. He'd once seen Sabrina yelling at her on the street, but she was speaking in French, so he didn't know what she was saying. Michael offered to help Sophie find a new job and place to live, but he never saw her again. Sabrina was also wrong in telling police that Sophie had been mingling with a rough crowd.
迈克尔感到震惊。他与萨布丽娜·夸代尔和威萨姆·梅多尼很熟，因为三人正在商谈合作事宜。他问索菲是什么原因导致了殴打。原因荒谬至极。她把黄油掉在地上了。迈克尔对索菲深表同情。他曾见过萨布丽娜在街上对她大喊大叫，但她用的是法语，所以他不知道她在说什么。迈克尔主动提出帮索菲找一份新工作和一个住处，但他再也没见过她。萨布丽娜告诉警察索菲与坏人混在一起也是错误的。
Truth was, she had barely socialized with anyone outside of Sabrina's home. Southfields was full of other foreign nannies, many of whom bonded together, but Sophie mostly kept to herself. Some noticed that Sabrina took advantage of Sophie's soft nature by making her work long hours and take on additional duties like cooking and cleaning. Sophie was particularly shy and quiet, which made her vulnerable to exploitation. A family friend named Steven witnessed Sabrina screaming at Sophie in French on several occasions. Sophie looked scared and hungry as though she was in some kind of trance.
事实是，她几乎没有与萨布丽娜家以外的任何人交往。南菲尔兹到处都是其他外国保姆，她们中许多人建立了联系，但索菲大多独来独往。一些人注意到萨布丽娜利用索菲温和的性格，让她长时间工作，并承担烹饪和清洁等额外职责。索菲特别害羞和安静，这使她容易受到剥削。一位名叫史蒂文的家庭朋友曾多次目睹萨布丽娜用法语对索菲尖叫。索菲看起来很害怕，很饿，仿佛处于某种恍惚状态。
Steven was so concerned that Sophie wasn't eating enough that he once brought food over for her. He confronted Sabrina about her aggressive behavior, but Sabrina said that Sophie was lazy and didn't do enough cooking. A former friend of Sabrina's named Nicole once visited the home to find Sophie on the floor and Sabrina attacking her. Nicole had to intervene as Sabrina tried to kick Sophie and hit her with a chair. Afterwards, Nicole was so worried about Sophie that she took her into her own home with the intention of helping her get back to France.
史蒂文非常担心索菲吃不饱，有一次甚至给她带了食物。他与萨布丽娜对质，指责她的攻击性行为，但萨布丽娜说索菲很懒，做的饭不够多。萨布丽娜的一位前朋友妮可曾去过家里，发现索菲躺在地上，萨布丽娜正在攻击她。妮可不得不介入，因为萨布丽娜试图踢索菲并用椅子打她。事后，妮可非常担心索菲，于是把她带到自己家里，打算帮她回法国。
Sabrina found out about it and turned up on Nicole's doorstep, quote, screaming like a mad woman. She stormed in and demanded Sophie get her stuff and return to the flat. Nicole asked Sabrina to calm down, but she was so livid that even Nicole was terrified of her. The extent of what Sophie Leonet was enduring in London was a secret she never revealed to her family in any of her correspondence to them back home. Sophie was from a modest family in Tois, a small provincial town in northeast France. It was the lack of employment opportunities in Tois that had brought her to London in the first
萨布丽娜发现了这件事，出现在妮可家门口，“像个疯女人一样尖叫”。她冲进去，要求索菲拿上东西回公寓。妮可让萨布丽娜冷静下来，但她非常愤怒，连妮可都对她感到恐惧。索菲·里昂内在伦敦所经历的一切，是她从未向家乡的家人透露过的秘密。索菲来自法国东北部一个小省镇图瓦的一个普通家庭。正是图瓦缺乏就业机会，才让她来到伦敦。
place. A qualified childcare worker, she believed that a temporary move would kick start her career and give her the chance to improve her English. The prospect of life in the big city excited Sophie. She loved the arts and sought a life surrounded by cinema, dance, and theatre. She responded to an ad to work as a live-in nanny and was thrilled to be hired by Sabrina Quedere. The glamorous woman and her celebrity-studded lifestyle played perfectly into Sophie's dream image of what life in London would be like. In 2016, just days after her 20th birthday, Sophie left France and moved into Sabrina's flat on
作为一名合格的儿童保育员，她相信暂时的搬迁会启动她的职业生涯，并让她有机会提高英语水平。在大城市生活的愿景让索菲感到兴奋。她热爱艺术，追求被电影、舞蹈和戏剧包围的生活。她回应了一则招聘住家保姆的广告，并很高兴被萨布丽娜·夸代尔录用。这位迷人的女性和她那充满名流的生活方式完美契合了索菲对伦敦生活的美好想象。2016 年，在 20 岁生日后几天，索菲离开法国，搬进了萨布丽娜位于
Wimbledon Park Road. The job started off well. Sophie got along with Sabrina's sons and looked forward to earning a decent wage. Sabrina even gave her a glamorous makeover, which Sophie proudly showed off on social media. But after about a year, Sophie told her parents she was bored and wanted to come home. She said there were tensions in the family and it was getting harder to take care of the children. She was made to sleep in the same bedroom as Sabrina's sons, which meant she had little time to herself. She also told her mother, Catherine, that she was not being paid. Catherine voiced these concerns to Sabrina, who reassured her that Sophie was being paid into an English bank account.
温布尔登公园路的公寓。工作开始得很顺利。索菲与萨布丽娜的儿子们相处得很好，并期待着赚取一份体面的工资。萨布丽娜甚至为她做了迷人的改造，索菲自豪地在社交媒体上展示了这一点。但大约一年后，索菲告诉父母她很无聊，想回家。她说家里有紧张气氛，照顾孩子变得越来越困难。她被迫与萨布丽娜的儿子们睡在同一个卧室，这意味着她几乎没有自己的时间。她还告诉她的母亲凯瑟琳，她没有拿到工资。凯瑟琳向萨布丽娜表达了这些担忧，萨布丽娜向她保证，索菲的工资是打入一个英国银行账户的。
Police tried to find the English bank account that Sabrina claimed Sophie was being paid into, but it didn't exist. It didn't appear that Sophie was being paid at all. Sabrina also urged Catherine to encourage her daughter to stay on, explaining she thought of Sophie like a sister and needed her around. It was clear that the feeling wasn't mutual when Sophie suddenly asked her mother for money so she could return to France. Catherine obliged, but Sophie never ended up purchasing a ticket home. Sophie's parents were devastated to learn the truth of what their daughter had endured in London. Had they known she was in any kind of trouble, they would have immediately travelled to help her.
警方试图找到萨布丽娜声称索菲工资打入的那个英国银行账户，但它根本不存在。索菲似乎根本没有拿到工资。萨布丽娜还敦促凯瑟琳鼓励她的女儿留下来，解释说她把索菲当作姐妹，需要她在身边。当索菲突然向母亲要钱以便回法国时，很明显这种感情并不是相互的。凯瑟琳答应了，但索菲最终没能买到回家的票。索菲的父母得知女儿在伦敦所经历的真相后悲痛欲绝。如果他们知道她遇到了任何麻烦，他们会立即赶去帮助她。
Investigators remained unconvinced that what they were being told was the full truth of what happened to Sophie. They ultimately charged both Wiesem Medunee and Sabrina Quedere with her murder and the obstruction of her body. The couple continued to assert that Wiesem interrogated Sophie alone and that her death was accidental. In the lead up to their trial, Wiesem offered to plead guilty to manslaughter, but the request was denied. Three days later, he turned the case upside down when he retracted his confession, claiming he'd been lying all along to protect Sabrina. Those who knew the couple were aware the relationship between Sabrina and Wiesem wasn't entirely even handed. Some friends thought Wiesem was, quote, punching above his weight, which led him to accept
调查人员仍然不相信他们被告知的是索菲遭遇的全部真相。他们最终以谋杀和妨碍尸体罪起诉了威萨姆·梅多尼和萨布丽娜·夸代尔。这对情侣继续坚称威萨姆独自审讯了索菲，她的死是意外。在审判前夕，威萨姆提出承认过失杀人罪，但请求被拒绝。三天后，他推翻了供词，声称他一直都在撒谎以保护萨布丽娜，从而使案件发生了逆转。认识这对情侣的人都知道，萨布丽娜和威萨姆之间的关系并不完全平等。一些朋友认为威萨姆是“高攀”，这导致他接受了
less than ideal treatment from Sabrina. Over the years when she left him for other men, Wiesem always welcomed her back. The truth according to Wiesem was that on the evening of Monday, September 18, he'd been asleep when Sabrina suddenly woke him up. She kept repeating, what have I done? What have I done? She told him Sophie was in the bath and wasn't breathing. Wiesem got up and found Sophie's lifeless body lying in the tub. He spent over an hour trying to revive her, but it was too late. She was already dead. Sabrina refused to call the police, suggesting they burned Sophie's body instead. Wiesem eventually relented because he wanted to protect Sabrina and keep her family together.
萨布丽娜不理想的对待。多年来，当她为了其他男人离开他时，威萨姆总是欢迎她回来。据威萨姆所说，真相是 9 月 18 日星期一晚上，他正在睡觉，萨布丽娜突然叫醒了他。她不停地重复：“我做了什么？我做了什么？”她告诉他索菲在浴缸里，没有呼吸。威萨姆起床，发现索菲毫无生气的身体躺在浴缸里。他花了一个多小时试图救醒她，但为时已晚。她已经死了。萨布丽娜拒绝报警，建议他们焚烧索菲的尸体。威萨姆最终屈服了，因为他想保护萨布丽娜并保持她的家庭完整。
He put Sophie's body in a suitcase and agreed to lie to the police. In his written statement, Wiesem said, I have always loved Sabrina and tried to protect her. This led me to make very regrettable choices. I should have been more assertive with Sabrina. Had I been, Sophie Lyonnais would probably still be alive. Wiesem went on to paint Sabrina as the hard cop when dealing with Sophie. On one occasion, Sabrina had forced Sophie into the bath and held her head under water in the beard of extracting a confession about Mark Walton. On another, she hit Sophie with an electric cable so hard in the legs that she couldn't stand or walk properly.
他把索菲的尸体装进手提箱，并同意向警方撒谎。在书面陈述中，威萨姆说：“我一直爱着萨布丽娜，并试图保护她。这导致我做出了非常令人遗憾的选择。我本应该对萨布丽娜更坚定一些。如果我这样做了，索菲·里昂内可能现在还活着。”威萨姆继续将萨布丽娜描绘成处理索菲问题时的“严厉警察”。有一次，萨布丽娜强迫索菲进入浴缸，并将她的头按在水下，试图逼供关于马克·沃尔顿的事情。另一次，她用电缆狠狠地抽打索菲的腿，导致她无法站立或正常行走。
Wiesem admitted that he'd done nothing to stop the attacks or seek medical help for Sophie. Sabrina had fully convinced him that Sophie was helping Mark Walton sexually abuse Sabrina's sons. He maintained that he had never hurt Sophie himself or been involved with any of the acts on the night she was killed. Investigators viewed Wiesem's confession with skepticism. By this point, they had spoken to Sabrina's youngest son, the one at the centre of the allegations against Sophie and Mark Walton. For the sake of clarity, case file will refer to him as Gareth. On the night of Monday, September 18, Gareth woke up to the sound of noises coming from the
威萨姆承认他没有采取任何行动来阻止这些攻击或为索菲寻求医疗救助。萨布丽娜完全说服了他，索菲正在帮助马克·沃尔顿性虐待萨布丽娜的儿子。他坚称自己从未伤害过索菲，也没有参与她被杀当晚的任何行为。调查人员对威萨姆的供词持怀疑态度。此时，他们已经与萨布丽娜最小的儿子谈过话，也就是针对索菲和马克·沃尔顿指控的核心人物。为了清晰起见，案卷将称他为加雷斯（Gareth）。9 月 18 日星期一晚上，加雷斯被从
family bedroom. He got up to see what was going on and noticed there was water spilling out from underneath the bathroom door. Inside, Gareth could hear the voices of his mother and stepfather. He also heard the sound of water splashing and Sophie's voice. The next morning, he noticed his mother seemed happy and relaxed. Gareth asked what had happened and Sabrina told him that Sophie was gone and they wouldn't be seeing her again. Gareth's statements placed both Sabrina and Wiesem at the scene of the crime, completely shattering the narrative that one of them acted alone in assaulting Sophie while the other person slept. With the couple refusing to tell the truth, investigators were left to charge
家庭卧室传出的声音吵醒。他起床查看发生了什么，注意到浴室门下有水溢出。在里面，加雷斯能听到他母亲和继父的声音。他还听到了水花四溅的声音和索菲的声音。第二天早上，他注意到他的母亲看起来很高兴且放松。加雷斯问发生了什么事，萨布丽娜告诉他索菲走了，他们不会再见到她了。加雷斯的陈述将萨布丽娜和威萨姆都置于犯罪现场，彻底粉碎了其中一人在另一人睡觉时单独袭击索菲的说法。由于这对情侣拒绝说出真相，调查人员只能起诉
them both with murder and pieced together their own conclusions based on the evidence. They believed that the couple had essentially held Sophie prisoner inside their home for six weeks. During this time, they confiscated her phone so she couldn't contact anyone without Sabrina being present. They withheld food until Sophie would say or agree with whatever they demanded just to eat. They also forced her to sleep in a tiny dark room where she withered away. They interrogated her so intensely and violently that they eventually wore her down enough to extract a false confession, which they dictated to her as she wrote it down. They likely aimed to use the confession to blackmail Mark Walton into giving them more money.
他们两人谋杀罪，并根据证据拼凑出自己的结论。他们认为这对情侣实际上将索菲囚禁在他们家中长达六周。在此期间，他们没收了她的手机，这样她就无法在没有萨布丽娜在场的情况下联系任何人。他们扣留食物，直到索菲为了吃饭而说出或同意他们要求的任何事情。他们还强迫她睡在一个狭小黑暗的房间里，在那里她日渐消瘦。他们对她进行了如此强烈和暴力的审讯，以至于最终将她折磨到足以提取一份虚假供词，并在她写下时口述给她。他们可能旨在利用这份供词勒索马克·沃尔顿，让他给他们更多的钱。
Sophie said and did everything the couple wanted in an effort to survive, even if she knew it wasn't true. Exactly how Sophie died and who had killed her remained a mystery. It also wasn't clear if she had been killed by accident during one of the torture sessions, or if the couple decided she had to die. Either way, police believe Sabrina and Wiesem collectively put Sophie's body in a suitcase and hid it under one of the children's beds while deciding how to dispose of it. They then went about their normal lives for the next two days, with CCTV footage capturing them going grocery shopping and taking the children to school like nothing had happened. So Sabrina and Wiesem's joint trial began in March 2018.
索菲为了生存，说了并做了这对情侣想要的一切，即使她知道这不是真的。索菲究竟是如何死亡的，以及是谁杀死了她，仍然是一个谜。也不清楚她是在酷刑期间意外死亡，还是这对情侣决定她必须死。无论哪种方式，警方认为萨布丽娜和威萨姆共同将索菲的尸体装进手提箱，并将其藏在其中一张儿童床下，同时决定如何处理它。接下来的两天，他们继续过着正常的生活，监控录像拍到他们像什么都没发生一样去买菜、送孩子上学。于是，萨布丽娜和威萨姆的联合审判于 2018 年 3 月开始。
Both pleaded guilty to perverting the course of justice by burning Sophie's body, but not guilty to her murder. It was an exhaustive trial that lasted 43 days, during which both defendants continued to blame one another for her death. On the stand, Sabrina said that Wiesem tortured Sophie in the bath by putting her head under water and by covering her mouth with a water-soaked towel. Sabrina shocked the court by claiming Wiesem demanded they have sex near Sophie's body to, quote, mark the occasion and she had obliged. Wiesem testified that Sabrina had killed Sophie and then asked for his help to cover up the crime. He said he didn't want to burn Sophie's body, but went along with the plan because Sabrina asked him
两人均承认焚烧苏菲尸体以妨碍司法公正，但否认谋杀罪名。这场审判耗时43天，期间两名被告不断将苏菲的死归咎于对方。萨布丽娜在证人席上称，威塞姆在浴缸里折磨苏菲，将她的头按入水中，并用浸水的毛巾捂住她的口鼻。萨布丽娜声称威塞姆要求他们在苏菲尸体旁发生性关系以“纪念这一时刻”，而她照做了，这一说法震惊了法庭。威塞姆则作证称是萨布丽娜杀害了苏菲，随后要求他帮忙掩盖罪行。他说自己并不想焚烧苏菲的尸体，但因为萨布丽娜的要求才参与了计划。
to. He said it felt disgusting and horrible. One of Sabrina's ex-boyfriends said unpredictable, unstable and obsessive behavior was typical of Sabrina. He described her as a, quote, fickle lunatic and said she took advantage of people weaker than her, quote. She would lie. Her behavior was strange. She was aggressive. Sometimes she was violent and pulled the hair of girls on the street just because of a look. She had a dual face, a dual personality. She was manipulative. She could charm and tell lies. She could be as lovable as she could be detestable. The prosecution pointed out that Sabrina had a track record of calling the police for a range of minor complaints. Once she had reported that Wiesem was working too hard and
他说这让他感到恶心和恐怖。萨布丽娜的一位前男友称，不可预测、不稳定和强迫性行为是萨布丽娜的典型特征。他形容她是一个“反复无常的疯子”，并说她会利用比她弱的人。她会撒谎，行为怪异，且具有攻击性。有时她很暴力，仅仅因为别人看了她一眼，就会在街上拉扯女孩的头发。她有两副面孔，双重人格。她善于操纵，既能迷人又能撒谎，既可爱又可恨。检方指出，萨布丽娜有因各种琐事报警的记录。有一次她举报威塞姆工作太努力，
another time she reported that a wooden toy was being used in their bathroom. It was revealed that in May of 2017 Sabrina had been diagnosed with depression and borderline personality disorder. The latter is characterized by emotional and mood instability, insecurity and impulsivity that can result in impaired social relationships. Sabrina's lawyer argued that his client's mental illness caused the rational delusions that led her to genuinely believe that Sophie Leone had been recruited by Mark Walton to facilitate the abuse of her family. He said Sabrina's behavior towards Sophie was, quote, entirely driven by illness in her desperation to obtain evidence of Mr Walton's abuse.
另一次她举报浴室里有一个木制玩具。据披露，2017年5月，萨布丽娜被诊断出患有抑郁症和边缘性人格障碍。后者表现为情绪和心境不稳定、缺乏安全感和冲动，可能导致社交关系受损。萨布丽娜的律师辩称，其当事人的精神疾病导致了非理性的妄想，使她真诚地相信苏菲·里昂是马克·沃尔顿招募来协助虐待她家人的。他说萨布丽娜对苏菲的行为“完全是由疾病驱动的”，因为她迫切想要获得马克·沃尔顿虐待的证据。
The prosecution described Sabrina and Wiesem as a truly toxic combination. Their unhealthy, myopic, all-consuming and groundless obsession with Mark Walton had deprived them of reason and turned Sophie into something less than human. They argued that Sophie was killed out of revenge and punishment for Mark Walton refusing to financially support Sabrina. While only the two defendants would ever know who killed Sophie, the prosecution stated that they were both equally responsible for coming up with the plan to destroy her body and escape responsibility for the horrendous crime. The presiding judge accepted that Sabrina had significant influence over Wiesem, but that didn't matter in the grand scheme of things.
检方形容萨布丽娜和威塞姆是一个极其危险的组合。他们对马克·沃尔顿那种不健康、短视、全神贯注且毫无根据的痴迷，使他们丧失了理智，并将苏菲非人化。检方认为，苏菲被杀是出于报复和惩罚，因为马克·沃尔顿拒绝在经济上支持萨布丽娜。虽然只有两名被告知道是谁杀害了苏菲，但检方表示，他们同样应对销毁尸体和逃避罪责的计划负责。主审法官承认萨布丽娜对威塞姆有重大影响，但这在大局中并不重要。
Wiesem was an intelligent and well-educated man who knew Sophie was in danger and did nothing to help her or put a stop to the abuse. Despite Sabrina's bizarre behavior, Wiesem also actively went along with the interrogation sessions without coercion. While understanding that Sabrina's mental illness played a role, the judge concluded that her behavior was ultimately driven by cruelty and a desire for revenge against Mark Walton. He was convinced that Sabrina intended to use Sophie's audio and written confession to blackmail Mark for financial gain. While Sabrina's mental illness could be blamed for her delusions, it couldn't explain the violent and brutal treatment of Sophie.
威塞姆是一个聪明且受过良好教育的人，他知道苏菲处于危险之中，却没做任何事来帮助她或阻止虐待。尽管萨布丽娜行为怪异，但威塞姆在没有受到胁迫的情况下，也积极参与了审讯过程。法官在理解萨布丽娜的精神疾病所起作用的同时，得出结论认为她的行为最终是由残忍和对马克·沃尔顿的报复欲望驱动的。他确信萨布丽娜打算利用苏菲的录音和书面供词来勒索马克以获取经济利益。虽然萨布丽娜的精神疾病可以解释她的妄想，但无法解释对苏菲的暴力和残酷对待。
The suffering and the torture you put her through before her death was prolonged and without pity. Sabrina Quedé and Wiesem Meduné were found guilty of the murder of Sophie Lionet. They were sentenced to life imprisonment with a minimum of 30 years. Nine months after Sophie's murder, her body was finally returned to France. Her mother, Catherine, would later remark, they took away my daughter's dignity and finally her life painfully ebbed away until she struggled to take her last breath in that bath. The case haunts Mark Walton, who was inadvertently pulled into the nightmare Sabrina created. In an emotional interview with Good Morning Britain,
你们在她死前施加的痛苦和折磨是漫长且毫无怜悯的。萨布丽娜·奎德和威塞姆·梅杜内被判谋杀苏菲·里昂罪名成立，被判处终身监禁，最低刑期30年。苏菲遇害九个月后，她的遗体终于被送回法国。她的母亲凯瑟琳后来感叹道：“他们夺走了我女儿的尊严，最终她的生命在痛苦中一点点流逝，直到她在浴缸里挣扎着吸入最后一口气。”这起案件一直困扰着马克·沃尔顿，他无意中被卷入了萨布丽娜制造的噩梦中。在接受《早安英国》的感人采访时，
Mark said, The hardest thing for me going to bed at night was knowing that Sophie was telling the truth every time that she was answering those questions and interrogations. She never met me. Many have questioned how Wiesem Meduné accepted Sabrina Quedé's implausible lies about Sophie, given he was an intelligent and sane man. The couple's case has since been labeled an example of folly adieu, a rare psychiatric syndrome where two individuals share an identical delusion. The delusion is typically shared from one person to another. In this case, Sabrina created the delusions regarding Sophie and Mark and then transmitted them on to Wiesem. His love for Sabrina prevented him from viewing her behavior critically and honestly. Instead,
马克说：“我晚上睡觉时最痛苦的事，就是知道苏菲在回答那些审讯问题时说的每一句话都是真的。她从未见过我。”许多人质疑，鉴于威塞姆·梅杜内是一个聪明且神志正常的人，他为何会接受萨布丽娜·奎德关于苏菲的荒谬谎言。这对情侣的案件后来被贴上了“感应性精神病”的标签，这是一种罕见的精神综合征，指两个人共享相同的妄想。这种妄想通常由一个人传给另一个人。在本案中，萨布丽娜制造了关于苏菲和马克的妄想，并将其传给了威塞姆。他对萨布丽娜的爱使他无法批判性且诚实地看待她的行为。相反，
he let himself believe in her twisted reality and by doing so enabled and emboldened her. Another example of the folly adieu phenomenon is the Ericsson twins, covered in episode 17 of Case File. As for why Sophie didn't leave or otherwise seek help, it's likely that she didn't feel able to. Sabrina and Wiesem intimidated and bullied her to the point that she felt completely powerless, physically, mentally, and financially. Police never found her passport or the money her mother had given her for a return ticket to France. It's suspected the couple took them away to prevent Sophie from escaping. While Sophie's exact reasonings for staying would never be known, investigators did find a short note that she had written shortly before her murder.
他让自己相信了她扭曲的现实，并以此助长和鼓励了她。感应性精神病现象的另一个例子是埃里克森双胞胎，在《案件档案》第17集中有介绍。至于苏菲为什么没有离开或寻求帮助，很可能是因为她觉得自己做不到。萨布丽娜和威塞姆恐吓并欺凌她，使她在身体、精神和经济上都感到完全无力。警方从未找到她的护照或她母亲给她的回法国的机票钱。据怀疑，这对情侣拿走了这些东西以防止苏菲逃跑。虽然苏菲留下的确切原因永远无法得知，但调查人员确实发现了她在遇害前不久写的一张短条。
It read, why me, I need help to stop them. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
上面写着：“为什么是我，我需要帮助来阻止他们。”目前该集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。